Wir haben es gerade gemeldet die absolute horror meldung während das ozonloch immer kleiner wird wird die ozonschicht immer dünner
eine forschungsgruppe vermutet illegale quellen von fckw und die new york times hat sie jetzt
aufgespürt klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich eine sehr sehr schlimme situation die ozonschicht schwindet und wir menschen sind der
uv-strahlung aus dem weltall hilflos ausgesetzt sie verursacht hautkrebs
und wer genauer hinschaut der sieht auch bei mir hier im gesicht eine narbe das war ein basaliom
hautkrebs ich bin ein opfer dieser entwicklung gewesen
und damit sich die ozonschicht wieder regeneriert und das nicht weiter passiert wurde schon vor geraumer zeit gegen die verursacher
vorgegangen flur
kohlenwasserstoff fckw er zerstört die ozonschicht glücklicherweise ist der verbrauch und auch die produktion seit dem montrealer
abkommen um rund 90 prozent zurückgegangen damals hat man beschlossen
dieses gas zu verbieten doch eine schnelle erholung der ozonschicht ist dennoch nicht zu erwarten das sagt die weltorganisation für meteorologie wmo
denn die schädlichen chemikalien die bauen sich extrem langsam ab eine zahl
macht allerdings hoffnung denn der ozongehalt der atmosphäre habe sich seit 2000 stabilisiert so studien bisher
aber das scheint nicht wirklich der fall zu sein eine studie aus der schweiz vom dortigen physikalisch meteorologischen
observatorium in davos hat nämlich das gegenteil heraus gefunden
und die ergebnisse sind absolut besorgnis erregend denn diese studie zeigt dass das ozonloch zwei mal kleiner wird doch die
ozonschicht über den tropen und den mittleren breiten dünnt weiter aus das fazit der
forschungsgruppe ist alarmierend denn es zeigt dass die ozonschicht noch nie so dünn gewesen ist wie heute
die schädlichen fckw sind wohl noch längst nicht geschichte alte kühlgeräte
werden noch längst nicht auf der ganzen welt ordnungsgemäß recycelt ein forschungsteam aus den usa äußert die vermutung
dass irgendwo heimlich noch größere mengen an fckw produziert werden durch die analyse verschiedene messmethoden
schließen sie darauf dass die gestiegenen emissionen in südostasien
lokalisiert werden können und jetzt hat die new york times die verursacher aufgespürt und was da passiert das ist wirklich ziemlich schlimm
demnach setzen illegale kühlschrank produzenten in ostchina das verbotenen tree chlor flur methan ein gas das
eben zu den verbotenen flur kohlenwasserstoffen gehört die kühlschrank produzenten sparen mit dem auf dem schwarzmarkt
besorgten gas bares geld und verwenden es deshalb weiter die new york tanz spürte die kühlschrank produzenten in der küstenprovinz
shandong auf wo in den fabriken die isolationsschicht von kühlschränken mit dem gas
aufgespannt wird der chinesischen regierung ist das problem wohl auch seit längerem bekannt aber lokale
parteifunktionäre scheinen die produzenten wohl zu schützen und zudem werden die fabriken wohl nicht
angemeldet und ziehen um wenn sie entdeckt werden seit januar gibt es neue handelsregeln für vorprodukte von drei
kilometern ob das die produktion einnehmen wird und diese dramatische entwicklung
stoppen wird das ist allerdings mehr als fraglich wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen themen ich hatte euch natürlich immer auf dem laufenden
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken der vorbericht horrormeldung die
ozonschicht ist so dünn wie noch nie bis dann
bleibt dran